by considering gradients sure that so we
required to prove and in the end equals
1 over and K all right now this part was
easier but some of you better felt like
but still what a month to be rotten food
a wolf abysm I think the reason why it's
wet so they do is because they told you
more or less how to do it because they
say by consider ingredients right so to
get gradients out of these things you
have to differentiate
okay so let's give it good this
derivative is going to be simple one
rattle it off okay
X to the N minus one okay derivative of
this nice and simple okay so now what I
do with the two derivatives I say that
and x equals a like this should be equal
great it's very cool okay sir I'm gonna
take each of these gradients and
evaluate F at x equals a nice that's
very cool so let's see
something here anything swap the a and
the in caricature / in pain multiply
through by a okay so put a times maybe n
minus one is one over in pain and your
index Louis I think you okay then okay
fine one month that was all about you
don't have to reckon alright now the
next part just read this question
carefully with you express K as a
function of n by eliminating a son what
does that mean our final point should be
K equals some blah blah blah blah blah
with ends in it and no 8 that's what it
means to say Express K as a function of
n now you can see here I almost have K
as a function of n during it I'm pretty
close yeah but I've got this pesky a
hanging around sir how do I get rid of
all APRA numeral out of an equation
what's the way what kinds of approaches
do we have that can eliminate
when I have to do some kind of
substitution right so here's one
equation in order to do some
substitution I'll need another equation
right now can you see I'm trying to walk
you through you look at this question
you're like how to do its stop right you
actually do you're just gonna be able to
access that problem-solving what kind of
equation can eyeball what information do
we know about this thing
it's a common tangent through the middle
okay we've already counted for the fact
that at that point their gradients are
equal
solutely is the same but we have it
accounted for the fact that if it's a
common tangent they also intersect at
that point no they actually exist at
that corner set quarters
so therefore not only can I say this
this is the statement about gradients I
can make a statement about these two
guys okay I can say when x equals a they
should be the same that okay all right
so here we go equation 1 equation 2 now
it just so happens you really could go
either way what suggestion do we have
for how we could try and put these
together
now let me just give you a up let's try
something let's try something which is
not going to work but when it fails its
failure will be instructive
I heard okay I look at this and I say
poor look that's this isn't it
Amy and here Amy and here that's cool
that looks good let's substitute 1 over
N K equals Lord and over pay then you're
like oh I can't see a common case sir I
suppose I could write 1 over N equals a
I did eliminate but I eliminated the
wrong thing yeah because I wanted a K in
there but I have limited the cake
that's a bit of an oops okay so what
should I do instead or is this useful to
me at all
he reckons it's useful yeah okay what
should I do with it
make a the subject should have an e to
the power
one on and what's that English that's
promising
because now wherever I see an A I can
get rid of it in the place of it okay so
where should I look where should I put
it
let's go with it so sub into one okay
let's do it
that a is gonna become a whole ^
wait sorry no Sookie are you buddy
nixsboys that's just okay and so what I
want a 1k is is subject so I'm switching
around with that by the way with the
critical steps there's one step here
that's more important than any of the
others I wonder what you think it would
be suppose we're done arguing metal I
reckon they're critical step is this one
that you might think that obvious okay
but my question is how do we get from
there sorry from the previous line to
that one the answer was we turn the log
equation into an exponential and that's
the key or alternatively we could have
gone vice versa we could it turn an
exponential equation into a long
equation the real problem the reason why
one and two can't just fit into each
other nicely you end up with this kind
of thing is that one's a log and one's
an exponential you have to get we're
talking the same language just like any
fractures and commented nominate on it's
just it's functions instead of fractions
okay now our last question I think was
on this is what shoe box with the box
now the answer is not given to you
right so you can automatically say one
of the marks would be there where would
we put the other mark probably on that
important line that's here okay
now in practice we don't have to name it
the agency - then after they come online
they could say our series on them but I
think that's kind of a grateful point
after that everything is really
elementary